With non-patterning knitting machines,
and any time you want to work
a hand-manipulated stitch pattern,
there's usually a lot
of counting of needles involved.
For simple stitch transfers,
you can use a pencil or a water-soluble
pen and simply mark the needle bed.
You could also use your needle
pushers to select sets of needles.
I found that cheat sheets come in handy
for more complicated stitch patterns.
We've created a set of sheets
for the various gauges of machines.
The grids are sized according
to the needle pitch.
That's the space between
the centers of the needles.
Here I'm using a 6.
5 millimeter gauge,
and the needles of my LK150 fit
exactly in the boxes of the grid.
I've marked my stitch
pattern sequence in pink.
I'll have two needles that will be small
cables over three rows,
and there will be six needles
in between that are going
to remain in plain knitting.
As I'm knitting, I just simply line up
the appropriate row on the cheat
sheet with my needle bed.
Pull out the needles
according to the chart.
I move the cheat sheet along the bed
for the width of my knitting,
and without having to count needles,
I'm now ready to do the hand manipulation.
Download a set of cheat sheets
from the Knit It Now website.
It includes all the common gauges
of domestic knitting machines,
from fine gauge to Bulky